what is he doing here
we found your daughter she's alive
be prepared for changes we have a child
therapist that she'll be working with
four years is a long time what she needs
right now is our family mr
sweetheart
it's mommy
welcome home esther we left it just as
it was
it's lovely to be back i miss my family
very much
our goal here is helping esther
acclimate back into life within the
family unit
[Music]
sorry
i think something's going on with esther
is there anything you want to tell me
about your time away
how's that possible four years ago she
was still drawing stick figures
esther's behavior has been so erratic
hello mommy
thank you mommy
i did notice some
what are inconsistencies getting at
to me it felt like a performance
if you're not esther who are you
[Music]
i need it for you
[Music]
[Applause]
the mother protects her family
no matter
that's the what of love
[Music]
these sessions are mandatory for all
staff sister anne
my mother struggled with depression
annie annie honey can i come in
both even as a child i knew it was annie
open the door please
more
[Music]
she said the voice didn't really want
her
it wanted me
the citadel has fallen black smoke
blocks out the sun because as some of
you may already know we have a female
student in the class only as an observer
so
let's descend into the mouth of hell
shall we
there are more possessions reported
today than at any other time in history
so we must fight for every soul
[Music]
defend us in battle against the spirits
of wickedness
i believe the demon that is tormenting
natalie and the demon that possessed my
mother are one in the same
i'd like to teach sister just enough to
protect herself and others
this relationship she has
it's personal
we've been waiting for you
your mother has a pretty voice
be careful
once you know the devil
the devils knows you
[Music]
[Music]
you don't have to be nervous i i'm not
nervous
well
so impressive you're impressive they're
going to be obsessed with you
they're not as nihilistic as they look
on the internet you guys this is me oh
whoa
this is your first relationship i don't
know you just kind of give that vibe
oh you know that has weed in there right
[Music]
who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
someone's doing is they're trying to
kill us off one by one that would be so
obvious if i were the
killer in the window for the neighbor
where are you
[Applause]
i'm staying safe really because it looks
like you're grabbing a meat cleaver to
go look for my boyfriend
[Applause]
you should watch your girl
you pushed her
[Music]
that all you
i got something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum i'm a hot girl pop girl rich girl
i'm a girl fast girl catch me if you can
go
[Music]
it's gonna be a hot one in los angeles
so it's on the agenda today
my eyes are closed
like every day
what are you doing in my room
hunter packs
ah
vampire honey is a business cut next
and cash your checks
[Music]
but things have changed since you got
your ass kicked out the union if i don't
come up with 10k my wife and my daughter
are going to move to florida hi dad
you're late again
and the union is the only place that
could give me that kind of money
your record is chock full of incidents
but he's a new man one last chance this
is your final warning
let's get cracking
vampires just trying to kill me now i
just pissed my favorite [ __ ] only
everybody pisses himself the first time
really yeah do you no i no no i didn't
but listen you did
you know what i see when i see a vamp
big old dollar sign
[Music]
vampires they're amongst us
and all they are is murderers
it's not eclipse new moon breaking dawn
0.1 it ain't like that all right
why do you know the names to all the
specific twilight films and what's your
gripe with breaking dawn part two it's
the exciting conclusion of the whole
twilight saga
welcome to the day shift [ __ ]
[Music]
works every
that they time
[Music]
[Music]
a horrible thing happened to you
i just want you to be able to move on
with your life
come here
it's coming up on a year
i have something that's planned and i
need a partner in crime the b67 tv tower
i haven't climbed since becky if you
don't confront your fears you are always
going to be afraid
[Music]
let's do it
let's climb your stupid tower
[Applause]
[Music]
i was really ripped you're awesome that
is the becky that we need for this trip
this is sick
damn it hunter what are you getting us
into
okay so just stay behind me one wrong at
a time
[Music]
see
it's easy
you're doing great
becky you gotta come up here
[Music]
hey trust me
what was that
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sure how do we get down
i don't have a signal
our water is down there in that bag we
have 50 feet of rope
i think i can drop myself lower
every hour that passes the weaker we get
if anyone call 9-1-1 they'd be here by
now
what is it that dan used to say if
you're scared of dying don't be afraid
to live
[Music]
rob zombie the director of house of a
thousand corpses halloween and the
devil's rejection brings you the
greatest love story ever told
oh i i don't like the sound of
the that of a super genius transplanted
into the body of a perfect physical
specimen
i want a man that makes my blood run
cold
a man that every time he enters my crypt
it's like a steak through my dead black
heart
i could whip the upper humpy down in the
lamb oh no remember what happened last
time he was batting
i'm gonna go
okay
i'm looking for a vision
a queen true love
what exactly do you want is herman
munster in there
i knew the moment i laid eyes on you
that you were special
i understand if you don't feel the same
i'm just a regular gal living a boring
normal life
if there's one thing i know is that the
rest of the world melted away
as soon as you appeared in my life it
seems miss lily is truly in love oh come
on you know and i know that we gotta get
rid of that bozo herman munster
[Music]
greetings from transylvania
[Music]
that's a strange way of saying hello oh
i guess we're gonna have to get used to
it
[Music]
if you're gonna do this
do it right
everything out stick with the plan
i don't take any stupid risks people die
every day at sea
we're almost there a couple more days
why don't we take one day off just relax
i'm sure don't stop on the islands of
despair you go past to paradise the
island the boat of despair for me
[Music]
on a boat there's one captain
you establish yourself to leave go away
right now she thinks she's got to be
wrapped around her little finger
maybe if you weren't jealous you
wouldn't be saying that kind of stuff
about my life it's got nothing to do
with me whatever magic you think you're
going to get better don't talk about my
wife i'll talk about her in the game way
i want to
[Music]
this woman
[Music]
she's bringing him down
[Music]
she's got you so twisted
you know up dangerous this is i don't
want you to come here no
she's gotta go
people die every day at sea
[Music]
welcome you have been chosen to spend 50
days in the immaculate room and will win
5 million by completing the task
enjoy your stay in the immaculate rome
wow
it's like we're in a dream it's a second
chance for us isn't it we should just be
grateful
that's it
smells like
nothing
so i guess this would be the master
bedroom very
white
this is your wake-up call
why do you think he's doing all this
professor voyam all anyone knows about
him is he's got more money than god and
that he's intrigued by the human
condition
it is midday i hate that clock it
actually went backwards
mikey
michael
how to get in here
they're just messing with us right
i really can take a treat
hey it's like what happens in here then
she just walked
i did out
know
this is gonna be fun
good night
i don't think i can do this anymore this
is all a little ridiculous what's going
on here not everyone's so easily
manipulated
not no no no how far would you go
i want to leave i'm going to take care
of you
you're the one doing this love is the
only real thing about you
enjoy your stay
hello june hello jennifer
i've recorded some questions here and
i've left enough space for you to answer
[Music]
what do you think of your new school
which do you like better
sunshine or rain
how was your day girls
he spoke to me and then it was just less
and less you know
if there's something you want to
communicate
you best say it
now jennifer
jones
how would you describe your
personalities i think you might be a bad
influence on each other it might be an
idea to split you up for a while
we will move the girls into special
education are i going to say anything
we'll get them to talk yeah guilty or
not guilty you need to take care of it
because please say something
how do you plead
they shall be institutionalized
indefinitely
[Applause]
if you were telling your story
how would it begin
in order to write a good book you need
to feel it have to be inspired
[Music]
i can't bear life without my sister
it's brought a new awakening in me i
could reach out and touch the stars i
could see the galaxy we can't go back to
the empty days before we finally feel as
though i'm swimming in a pool taste the
bittersweet smell of salt
it's like god gave me a chance to get
a challenge to prove who i really am
[Music]
why is sexual harassment so pervasive
and so hard to address
let's interrogate the whole system
hi my name is jody cantor i'm an
investigative reporter for the new york
times
what have you got i was told that the
wrongdoing in hollywood is overwhelming
i don't want to be quoted
period understood
in your previous stories how did you
persuade women to tell you what had
happened to them
a case i made was i can't change what
happened to you in the past
but together we may be able to help
protect other people
[Music]
the truth basically
what is it exactly that we're looking at
here these young women walked into what
they all had reason to believe were
business meetings
i can still see it the hotel room the
floor plan
he kept trying to touch me
i
asked him to leave me alone
instead they say he met them with
threats and sexual demands i was young
scared hi
we're from the new york times i believe
he used to work for harvey weinstein
people have tried to write this story
before he kills it every time harvey
adamantly denies any allegation of
result he played people he was a master
manipulator
will you give me just one chance to talk
to you are you sure that this isn't just
young women who want to sleep with a
movie producer to try to get ahead
this is bigger than weinstein this is
about the system protecting abusers
the women who receive these settlements
they can't speak out they'll be sued if
they do but if someone could speak
freely about the payouts
what payouts john
you have to imagine that every call you
make has been recorded and you're being
followed can you imagine how many
harveys there are out there you want to
get me killed
do you wish you hadn't signed up for
this story do you
no
the only way these women are going to go
on the record is if they all jump
together
we're all here harvey who
have you talked to
i have three daughters and i don't want
them to ever accept abuse or bullying
i'll go on the record
go right
it's time to write
this is all going to come up
i was silenced
i want my voice back
[Music]
every step you take
you're moving forward a moment in time
but what if for every step you take
backwards
you move backwards in time
[Music]
i'm 11.
a number that looks like two people
standing next to each other this is our
last weekend before middle school i
don't want to go backwards not forward
when is the person you used to be
and the other one
is the person you're becoming let's go
back like two months then we can have
somewhere all over again
and the older i am
the more complicated my life gets
that can't be real
of course it's real
he's dead
we make a pact
to try and find out who he was
this is on us
[Music]
daisy say something to you you can't not
look for someone who's gone
someone is waiting for this guy to come
home
[Music]
those are some tough years
it can be so hard to know what's right
you'll make it through
[Music]
you remember when it used to be better
to be older
it doesn't seem all that great
i don't want this weekend to end
[Music]
i don't want us to end
you'll never find another
[Music]
growth has a program where they take all
the top managers to italy
amber pack your bags
what you're going to italy
i have a feeling you're going to fall in
love okay i was kind of thinking of that
too
[Music]
ciao
welcome everyone i would like to
introduce our ceo nick martucci ciao i
meet you
he's my assistant cat
i'm excited to get to know you a little
better
[Music]
what roles do love and affection play in
your life where's this going
i'm really happy you're here amber
i can't afford this it's next street
[Music]
you seem so open-minded
why does everyone keep telling me that
[Music]
listen i think something weird might be
going on
look guys
next nixon the study working what is
this clue he's killing colonel mustard
with the lead pipe
[Music]
[Music]
this program sucks
lighten up a little bit please
[Music]
anyone else have anything they want to
say
franklin
i uh took some steps in setting healthy
boundaries and locked my dad online he's
never really been there for me when i
needed him and i'm done with that did
you delete your profile kind of the main
way i was uh staying in touch with you
my ex blocked me one time and i just
started a different page under a
different name i'll check it all the
time she never even knew
[Music]
i just started a different age under a
different name
i met someone
online she's like smart funny and you've
like talked to her on the phone and
stuff
obviously
soup
so how's it so
how's it going good this is creepiest
this was your idea that was my
ex-girlfriend this is your child i mean
what if he's already masturbating today
would you be up for a quick phone call
it's just a little weird that we've
never actually talked could you call him
and be the voice
what are you wearing sweatpants and a
red sock shirt what about you just a
dress no panties
[Music]
this is incest no it's not i'm doing
this to help him he thinks he's in a
relationship this girl's the love of my
life keep your expectations low she
could be like mean or or a scammer or
your dad
[Music]
all right it's my girlfriend one sec
hello
hey becca hello hello i'll call you in a
little bit
not there huh
can i pretend kiss you
but you ask for my help internet kiss
your son that's gross you love them yes
sip kiss them already
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Applause]
how is the girl
everything is well sir
[Music]
she sleeps sandy
your appetite is good
always as it should be
you must prepare the girl to leave
[Music]
have you never wondered what it would be
like to be someone else
mia
mia
she's awaking
[Music]
how is the goal
[Music]
you must ask the masters for help
have you informed our masters
[Music]
have you informed our masters
don't try to talk
i'm going to take care of everything
you mustn't be afraid
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
this year is beautiful
um what was that
okay okay
guys it's fine dolphins are a good sign
really
oh my god
[Music]
you